welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is John Romer the Elizabeth s and a
Varrick stout professor of political
science and economics at Yale University
his research concerns political economy
and distributive justice professor Romer
is a fellow of the econometrics society
a past Guggenheim Fellow and Russell
Sage fellow a fellow of the American
Academy of Arts and Sciences and a
corresponding fellow of the British
Academy he has published many articles
and books in economics political
philosophy and political theory
including political competition equality
of opportunity theories of distributive
justice and a general theory of
exploitation and class today we talk
with him about a book he has recently
written in collaboration with a myrtle
of lavador and Joaquin Silvestri titles
sustainability for a warming planet
welcome professor Romer thank you so
nice to have you back on the show again
yes let's start with an overview of the
book please tell us about it well I
would like to start talking about the
carbon budget okay sort of so people
understand what my problem is we have we
have emitted since the Industrial
Revolution a lot of billions of tons of
carbon into the atmosphere which leads
to concentration of carbon we've emitted
carbon dioxide and methane which
contains carbon and as we fill the
atmosphere up with more carbon the
global temperature rises computations by
many scientists indicate that we can we
have a remaining budget I'll say what
that means in a second of about 360
gigatonnes of carbon that can be emitted
from fossil fuels in
century before we reach a global
increase in temperature of two degrees
Celsius over the pre-industrial level
temperatures say 1850 okay and the
various climate catastrophes that we've
already seen droughts heat waves rising
water levels in some parts of the world
the volatility in climate which is
increased are all a consequence of an
increase in carbon of an increase in
global temperature of less than 1 degree
Celsius we've increased global
temperature from 1850 as a consequence
of our carbon emissions thus far by
about three quarters of a degree Celsius
so to go up to two degrees is already
going to push it engender a lot more
climate volatility than we've seen many
people take two degrees as the upper
limit of what we should as lower limit
sorry the upper limit of what we should
aim for other people say we could go
higher without great dangers but anyway
let's take the 2 degree limit so we can
only emit about as I said 360 Giga tons
of carbon from fossil fuels and the rest
of the century if we don't want to
exceed that temperature that temperature
is generally considered to be equivalent
to having a global concentration a
concentration of carbon in the
atmosphere of about 450 parts per
million
we're now at 400 parts per million ok
now in 2014 globally we emitted 9.8 Giga
tons of carbon a little less than 10 we
don't have the numbers yet for 2015 but
it's going to be about the same as that
may be slightly less if we kept on
emitting at that rate we would burn
through our budget of 360 Giga tons of
carbon from fossil fuel in about 33
years ok but we but this is a budget for
the rest of the century so that's the
problem the problem is how can we
reduce carbon emissions in order to stay
within our carbon budget which we think
will engender global temperature rises
of two degrees Celsius and our concern
in the book is to address this question
not only from an economic viewpoint but
from an ethical viewpoint okay
and there are two large ethical issues
the question is what's the fair way of
allocating the budget that we have
remaining over the present and future
generations if we think of a generation
as 25 years the next century in involves
about three or four generations right
and the other question is what's the
fair way of allocating the budget across
regions of the world
we attempt to address both those
questions okay
the particular theory that we put forth
that is to say we base our ethical view
on a concept of sustainability now let
me explain what we mean by sustained
sustainability is used throughout the
environmental movement and their various
different ways in which the word is
employed what what's called strong
sustainability means that we actually
preserve physically what's on the earth
for future generations that is to say
the species of the forests and so on we
take we don't take that notion of strong
sustainability we take a notion of weak
sustainability which is that we preserve
the welfare or the standard of living
let's call it welfare it's more
encompassing than standard of living
that we preserve the welfare of people
on the world so their welfare doesn't
fall in particular what we call pure
sustainability means to find the path of
resource use across regions of the world
and across generations which would
guarantee the highest level of welfare
that can be achieved consistent with all
generations and all regions receiving
that level of welfare that's all right
now if we actually calculate that path
resource use and by resource use I don't
only mean carbon emissions I mean how do
we how much investment do we decide to
make in capital how much we want to do
we want to educate people how much do we
want to commit to research and
development which will further
technological change which will reduce
reduce carbon emissions so we look at
the whole gamut of what an economy has
to decide and the path of resource use
is a complete description in a
simplified way we have a model is a
complete description of the path of
resource use across generations and
across regions of the world
now if we try to find the path that will
guarantee the highest level of welfare
consistent with that level of welfare
being sustainable indefinitely
there'd be no growth in welfare every
generation would have the same amount of
welfare and that's not a very appealing
proposition
why because our own welfare is so much
massively higher than the welfare people
200 years ago and we value the fact that
our welfare is improved and we should
probably desire that the welfare
continue improving so we're not no
growth people we think growth ISM is
very important growth is important
because it increases the standard of
living it increases life expectancy it
increases the extent to which people can
realize their themselves and their plans
and also from a political point of view
growth is probably the politically
easiest way of bringing up the standard
of living of the poor in particular the
global poor right right I mean it'd be
fine it'd be great if we could
redistribute very simply income and
wealth from the rich to the poor but
given that that's difficult a simpler
less contestable way of increasing the
welfare of the global poor is to have
economic growth so we think that most
people would like to have growth that is
to say they'd like to have a welfare
level slightly lower than they could
have on this pure
sustainable path if they invest more in
the future and thereby permitting
economic growth to occur okay so what we
call growth sustainability is the
following pick a growth rate that we're
happy with donating to the future say a
growth rate of 1% of welfare a year
could have said 2% but I pick 1% for a
reason okay and you'll tell us I will
tell you the question is if we take 1%
is it possible to design a plan of
resource use so that all generations
continue to have a welfare level of at
least 1% higher than the previous
generation and this goes on forever now
if we did that we would in fact have to
solve the climate problem because
increasing welfare of 1% includes the
fact that people's welfare is affected
by global warming and if we break our
carbon budget it's likely that welfare
for lots of people is going to decrease
massively so if we could do this since
the since the costs - person's welfare
the disutility that the person
experiences from a warming world counts
we would also be solving the carbon
problem ok so that's the other thing we
do in the book we tried it we compute
given our model what the path of
resource use is that would stay within
the carbon budget that we have and
increase welfare for all reasons of the
world in all generations at the rate of
28 percent per generation which is
equivalent to 1% per year in a 25 year
generation ok that is a lot of
information to take in so you've been
working on this book for a while now how
long has it one of decade about a decade
so over over the course of that decade
have you had to modify any of your
assumptions I'll call them well I think
the more we've learned as we've studied
the problem and worked on our model the
we've been we've had some surprises and
what we've learned ok and what were they
well one question that we didn't know
the answer to before we started is the
following
let me explain the inter-regional
problem a little bit ok to pose the
question properly let's take an example
of China in the United States China is
growing faster than the United States
its level of welfare per capita is
growing faster than ours although our
level of welfare is quite a bit higher
than the Chinese level consumption
education knowledge and so on we believe
that the only possible way of allocating
the carbon budget across regions of the
world in the next two or three
generations is going to be one which
maintains the date at which China would
have converged to the global north in
welfare per capita or let's say standard
of living per capita let's say that we
could compute that if we didn't have to
worry about the climate problem and
economic growth just continued the way
it's been going for the last 50 years or
so or in China the last 30 years that
China would converge to the global North
that is to say Europe in the United
States and the highly developed
countries in standard of living in 75
years that's not a bad guess actually we
can justify some people say 60 some
people say 100 but 75 years is not a bad
conjecture we think that the politically
feasible way of dividing the carbon
budget between the global South and the
global north is to preserve the dates of
convergence of countries in the global
south to the global north so if China
would have converged in 75 years
the allocation of carbon emissions to
China and the US should be such that
convergence continues to be in 75 years
mm-hmm
the convergence may be at a somewhat
lower level of welfare than it would
have been if we didn't have to worry
about the carbon problem because we're
gonna have to all massively cut back on
emissions but we think the date of
convergence should be maintained and we
argue in the book that that's a
politically necessary does it or autumn
or condition because imagine what would
happen if a proposal were on the table
which entailed that the United State
that China would catch up the United
States in a hundred years
suppose the Chinese economists could
compute that they're gonna say look at
we would have converged to you in 75
years under what's called business as
usual we didn't have to worry about the
carbon problem and now you're retarding
our date of convergence by 25 years and
why should we accept that and conversely
if a proposal were on the table saying
that we should converge the Chinese
reconverge to the global north in 50
years the United States will say well
you would have converged in 75 years why
should the fact that we're all facing
the same crisis mean that you converge
to us sooner so we think that it will be
much easier in particular for these
countries to convince their citizenry's
of the plan which will involve some
national sacrifices increase in gasoline
taxes and so on cut back cut back in
carbon use if the date of convergence is
maintained so what we do is we ask the
question what is the method that
resources should be used how how should
our economies grow so that first of all
China continues or the global South more
generally continues to have dates of
convergence which are unchanged from
what they would have been to the global
north and secondly stays within our
carbon budget right
okay and thirdly no country should grow
too slowly we're a little more explicit
about that and we find that the answer
to that question is that the global
North on the optimal resource path which
satisfies these criteria can grow at
about one percent a year for the next 75
years and after and thereafter about 1
percent a year ok now China similarly
will have to cut back its growth rate
from what it was would have been not to
1% but there's something somewhat lower
than what would have been the case the
dates of convergence will remain the
same
ok so that involves that really is
stating the problem that if we want to
solve this crisis that we're in in a
fair way and we think this idea of
maintaining the dates of convergence it
might be not the fairest way of doing it
but we think it's the politically
feasible way of doing it ok that we're
gonna have to cut back our growth to
about 1% a year ok but in the mean time
you had said earlier that we have until
about 35 years to cut back on our carbon
no I didn't I said if we continue using
emitting carbon I've had at the rate
that we're currently doing so we will
burn through our entire budget for the
rest of the century in about 30 years
all right yeah we can't do that we have
to cut back massively in the amount of
carbon right right so what's the plan
for that do you have any kind of
strategy that you put forth well we I
can tell you what the path will be we
define the model our model works in 25
year generations so as I said in 2014
globally we produced about 9.8
gigatonnes of carbon from emissions from
fossil fuels we have to cut that back to
about for the neck for the 25 years we
started at 2010 for the 25 years from
2010 to 2030 5 we have to
cut back to about eight point four seven
Giga tons of carbon for the 25 years
after that I don't remember I have to
look at my chart in here for the 25
years after that we have to cut back to
about three point four one Giga tons
that's globally so that's everyone on
the planet working towards these goals
and for the 25 years after that we have
to cut back to one point four seven Giga
tons of carbon
oh that's a pretty massive cut back
exactly do you think that's feasible we
make rather conservative assumptions we
don't depend upon a deus ex machine of
the discovery of some magnificent
technology that's going to produce
energy without carbon we simply
extrapolate the rate at which technology
has gotten better in terms of producing
dollars of output per unit of carbon
emitted we extrapolate that rate over
the next centrally century where we take
account of the fact that in our resource
use we're going to be investing more in
research and development than we have in
the last period and so that rate may
increase because the more research and
development we do on technology the more
we can we can improve the technology so
and dajin izing how much research we do
which is what the model does we think
that it's feasible to do this that's
what we calculate it is feasible
now as I say it's pessimistic because
we're taking the econometric estimation
of how the carbon intensity of
production decreases is estimated from
past data and maybe we'll have some kind
of you know wonderful discovery which
will create a technology that can
produce energy without without emitting
carbon maybe maybe for some reason maybe
we'll learn how to really harness solar
solar an injury and and other kinds of
non-fossil fuel energy to do this but we
don't depend on that in the book so in
that sense it's a it's a conservative
so in working with the two other
gentlemen on this book how did you do
the research well we met quite
frequently and we talked about what we
were doing and what our plans were and
we assigned out different
responsibilities to different people to
focus on you know different parts of the
work because the work involves a lot of
economic theory we had to figure out how
to compute what these optimal paths were
for sustainability and that was a new
economic theory because most economists
have not used the concept of
sustainability in studying the the
climate change problem they've used
something called discounted
utilitarianism right and let's talk
about that a little bit because you're
you're you do depart from what is
generally other scholars generally have
thought on this topic so tell us about
well the standard approach that has been
used in growth theory in economics goes
back to mathematician named Frank Ramsey
who worked in the late 1920s brilliant
mathematician who today he might be
called a mathematical economist who
wrote down the first models of modeling
economic growth and what we know we
should aim at it and the models he used
imagined or stipulated that there would
be that there's one average
representative household at each
generation and it has a utility function
which which defines what its welfare
level will be as a function of its
consumption and it assumes that the
utility function is the same for every
generation and then it it tries to
maximize the discounted some of those
utilities across generations what is
discounting mean it means that the
utility of the first generation counts
for one unit I mean its utility but you
don't add to that the utility of the
second generation you add say 0.98
utility of the second generation and the
third term is 0.98 squared
time's the utility of the third
generation and so you geometrically
discount the weight that you put on
future generations and you try to find
the path of resource use that will
maximize that discounted sum okay now we
don't think that that's as good an
approach as doing what we do which is to
find the resource path that allows
utility to grow at a constant growth
rate those are different objectives
different social objectives in
particular the economists who use
discounted utilitarianism we think
discount the utility of future
generations by far too much so for
instance Bill Nordhaus also at Yale
discounts the utility of each generation
at a rate of about 2% so the second
generation is you utility gets away to
0.98 and the third 1.98 squared
excuse me that's not generations that's
per annum 2% per annum okay so the
consequence of this assumption is that
or maybe 1.5 percent per annum is that
the utility of people living a hundred
years from now only counts about 13
percent as much as our utility and why
is that
let me just okay before explaining what
the justification is let me say why I
think that's wrong
I think the only and so in particular
we're giving very little weight to
people in the future their welfare and
we say that's impermissible that the
utility of future people counts as much
as ours and the only justification for
discounting future utility is the
possibility that future generations
might not exist there'll be some massive
crisis it could be induced by climate
could be a meteor hitting the earth but
it is okay it's ethically okay to
discount future generations because
there is a probability they won't be
here but for no other reason
now how do we compute what approximately
the discount rate should be right if I
if we were doing discounted
utilitarianism as I said Bill Nordhaus
uses 1.5 percent or two percent a year
other people use smaller numbers but let
me just explain what we think the
correct way of computing this is the
human species has been around for let's
say a hundred thousand years that's
about four thousand generations let's
say the probability that we made it this
far was one-half we did make it this far
let's just say back of the envelope
let's say they probably does one half
from that you can compute what the
probability of disappearance in each
generation was you say it's a constant
probability of disappearance over all
these generations what would that
probability be to generate a probability
of our having existed a hundred thousand
years of 1/2 turns out that it's 0.001
seven that's the probability for for
each generations being the last one now
Nordhaus is using 0.015 that's 1.5 so
the true probability that should be used
to discount future utilities is several
orders of magnitude three orders of
magnitude smaller than what Bill
Nordhaus is using for those who know the
stern report it's also two orders of
magnitude at least smaller than what
Nicholas internews is in the stern
report so we think that these
calculations are just not ethically
cogent okay the ones with these very
large discount rate okay so you know
what is your hope for the book I mean
why did you write the book and what
would you like people to take away from
it well we would the book is mainly
written for economists it's a technical
book we're thinking about writing a
simpler version of it for
more you know consumption by more people
without all the equations but at the
moment this is what we have and the main
purpose is to carry out a debate within
the economics profession about how we
should think about future generations
and apply that to the climate problem I
mean I guess our greatest hope would be
that we have some influence on how we
actually solve the climate problem in
particular that people think of there
being a responsibility towards future
generations and and adopting the idea
that maintaining the date of convergence
of the global South to the global north
which will be different in different
countries should be present is a very
good we think rule of thumb for
calculating what the allocation of
carbon resources should be and do you
think it's feasible yes well I mean our
paths though the whole purpose of the
computation is to show what's feasible
given our economies given the laws of
motion of economies and so on now let me
make a comment about a level of
abstraction of the book we don't discuss
issues of let's say should we tax carbon
or should we have cap-and-trade those
issues are important but they're not as
important as the question of deciding
how the carbon should actually be used I
mean what the actual allocation of
carbon should be two places in the world
before you use cap-and-trade you have to
know how much each region is allocated
and that's the problem we're trying to
use we're trying to solve the we think
cap-and-trade is probably a good way of
doing it taxes may be a good way of
doing it but in any case we have to
theoretically you have a conception of
what we want the allocation of carbon
budget to be the different regions of
the world before we can before we can
apply these techniques and ultimately
what do you conclude in the book
well we conclude that
i mean--if from a political point of
view the main I think problem for
implementing successful global
cooperation on this matter is the
American Republican Party because the
American Republican Party is not
admitting that we have to do any
cutbacks in carbon and you said all
they're denying the existence of the
link between fossil fuel consumption and
and carbon concentration in the
atmosphere in global temperature and
really there's no other really important
institution in the world as important as
the you as the US Republican Party which
takes this position so that's going to
hold back the level of cooperation the
Paris talks which occurred in December
last December which were the twenty
first meeting of the the group that has
met over the last since 1990 the
international group to talk about trying
to solve the problem were much more
successful than previous meetings they
really made headway but part a large
part of that headway was based upon the
fact that President Obama made promises
about how much the US would cut back in
carbon production those promises were
then met by the Chinese the European
Union had already made such promises and
about a hundred and fifty countries came
to these meetings making promises about
what their cutbacks would would be some
of these promises are contingent on
getting aid report some of the promises
of poor countries are contingent upon
getting a certain amount of aid from the
global north to implement these changes
in their technology but at least people
countries came with promises now if the
United States doesn't fulfill its
promises that's gonna that's going to
destroy the whole agreement and
yesterday I think or two days ago the
Supreme Court dealt a blow dealt a blow
to the efforts of to some states have
taken the view that they're not going to
implement
recommend the EPA regulations that have
come down through the Obama
administration for cutting back
emissions mainly from from use of coal
and the Supreme Court had to decide
whether they were allowed to do this and
they decided two days ago that they
weren't that they're not gonna make a
final decision on it yet and it'll
probably be so they're gonna permit the
states these states that are non
co-operators to not cooperate at least
probably for the next year and that's
gonna really throw a wrench and throw a
spanner as the British say and the and
the possibility of of getting this
global cooperation off the ground
scary times in terms of climate these
days so hopefully you'll your book will
make a difference and help people on the
right path moving forward thank you for
being here to us and sharing some of
your work for more information about
professor Romer and his research please
visit our website at macmillan report
yale.edu be sure to join us again for
another episode of the Macmillan report
made possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and area studies at Yale